is Robert Pattinson going batty fans are
taking to social media to voice their
concern following the publication of an
in-depth piece in GQ entitled Robert
Pattinson a dispatch from isolation in
its the actor describes his existence
kicking around the London apartment in
which he's hunkered down or production
on the Batman is paused due to the
corona virus outbreak that concern is
twofold for the movie and for the actor
himself as far as the film goes it
appears that Pattinson isn't exactly
following the kind of workouts and
exercise regimen that one might expect
from the star of a highly anticipated
superhero movie he revealed that his
trainer left him with a BOSU ball and
the weight that have basically been
gathering dust in the corner since his
quarantine began it begs the question
what's our person son's thoughts on
working out drone the quarantine he told
GQ I think if you're working out all the
time you're part of the problem you set
a precedent no one was doing this in the
70s even James Dean he wasn't exactly
ripped
well no but James Dean never played
Batman either but instead also shared
that he called his co-stars zoe kravitz
to see how she was getting along that
during their production shut down and
that she told him she'd been working out
five days a week in isolation to prepare
for her role as Catwoman the star
admitted that he's quote barely doing
anything which is relatable but it's not
just his alleged inactivity that has
fans raising their eyebrows judging by
some of the words and actions relayed by
gqueues interviewer isolation has not
been terribly kind to Pattinson psyche C
madness as you know is like a star
admitted that he has had trouble keeping
track of time even under normal
circumstances and that he quickly lost
all track of time after he entered
lockdown he described feeling a profound
sense of terror even at the thought of
going out for a jog and his worry that
the Batman's producers were just kind of
forget he's there
it's the article subscription of
Pattinson 'he's insane culinary
endeavors though that really has fun
scratching their heads the star seems a
bit obsessed with microwaving pasta for
one thing a meal that he emits is quotes
actually quite revolting why you what do
you want
to do that then well because he's had a
great idea for a business he said what
if pasta really had the same kind of
fast-food credentials as burgers and
pizzas I was trying to figure out how to
capitalize in this area of the market
and I was trying to think how do you
make a pasta which you can hold in your
hand if you okay buddy
the lighthouse really mess you up that
bad next to Pattinson took things one
step further when he attempted to whip
up a batch of his patented pasta dish or
facetiming with the interviewer the
ingredients were as follows
penne pasta cornflakes any kind of sauce
and an absolute mess of cheese and sugar
or microwaved of course and wrapped up
in aluminum foil yup your next Batman
really did both aluminum foil in his
microwave and D up it basically exploded
while more than a few denizens of the
Twitterverse seemed genuinely concerned
that the star might have a few baths
than the old belfry we're of the opinion
that Pattinson is simply kind of a
goofball and he was just having a little
fun as many of us would be if we were in
his situation
[Music]
[Applause]
we're sure the actor is just fine really
mr. Pattinson if you stumble upon this
low maybe do a push-up from time to time
you've got to be Batman soon also you've
got to start boiling the pasta man it
works much better that way and usually
nothing explodes emphasis on util II the
Batman will fly into theaters on October
1st 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]